[Music]
now flooding can be expected after heavy
rain but just how severe can it get
really hard to predict yeah so as you
can see here a living room turned into a
river as water just rushed into that
home friday tonight the cleanup
continues for a family who was living on
the east side of town that's where we
find victoria saha joining us now live
with a closer look at that damage
yeah just about everything that was
inside the home has now been scattered
all around this front lawn in hopes that
if it airs out it could be saved it's
just a portion of what the damage the
damage that the flood has caused
there was more water inside than there
was outside at that point serene temple
describes her living room transformed
into a lake as water quickly rose to her
ankles
you can see the water line
how high it was in here topple's home
and yard flooded making it difficult for
her kids and pets to live in
are you scared so scared i don't think
he's ever going to want to go swimming
ever again huh are you going to want to
swim temple says there was no way to
start the cleanup until the water
drained but there was one issue the
drain by her house that clark county is
responsible for was clogged until you
see neighbors clearing it went from like
oh that's a lot of rain too
oh my god that's a little river okay
that's a giant river
and i knew before it came in the house
the flood destroyed a majority of
temple's belongings along with their
prized artwork i painted all of this
when i was 18. tumble rents the house
she says a restoration company started
the cleanup and on tuesday fans provided
by the company were still blowing in
every room
but while we were there the company was
told by the homeowner to take the
equipment out i'm in shock because this
is supposed to be running for at least
another week
temple doesn't know if she can continue
living in the house if damage isn't
fixed
i called the homeowner max carter to
find out why the cleanup stopped he said
no comment and he hung up the phone i
also reached out to the county about the
storm drains
and they said that they're cleared out
every month also when it storms victoria
saha 8 news now
victoria thanks for that as we continue
to navigate through a pretty intense
monsoon season there are several
resources to help you address flooding
issues you might have in your area you
can just head to the regional flood
control district's website there you can
report those clogged storm drains that
she was talking about and you can also
check to see if maybe your home might be
in a flood zone you'll also find a
helpful section about flood insurance as
well